[Music]
VW's facelift of the gulf models
included a technology update for their
electric drive
now both the all-electric zero-emission
version and the hybrid deliver enhanced
performance and an improved electric
range
[Applause]
we look first at the GTE
[Music]
once the car Testament escribe explains
that GTE signifies the plug-in hybrid
version of EWS bestseller the VW Golf
GTE powertrain pairs a 1.4 liter
four-cylinder gasoline engine delivering
110 kilowatts with an electric motor
together they put out 150 kilowatts
that's what the spec sheet promises and
that's pretty much what the model
delivers in practice like a new Montes
defines a plug-in hybrid as a car that
can run solely on electricity or with
support from its gasoline engine a
switch sets the driving mode with
settings for all electric hybrid and a
charge battery mode leave Moto's one
dynamo dose in DM G battery
forsooth glad that I'm finally mutters
points out that a frequent problem of
all-electric driving is that people
can't hear you especially when you're
moving slow so the developers put in a
switch that activates a low droning
sound enough to make pedestrians and
bike riders aware of the car's presence
father Buda Foose kanga of myelin
effects on much also new is the GT e--'s
ability to use the navigation system to
optimize the interaction between the two
drive systems along the planned route
maybe 50 kilometres montes adds that if
the golf GTE is 50 kilometer range is
not enough there is an alternative and
that's the e-golf the considerably
larger battery gives it a range up to
300 kilometers on electric power only
while it dispenses with a gasoline or
diesel engine completely aside from the
design tweaks that came with the goals
facelift the new Volkswagen e-golf can
boast a vastly increased range its
lithium ion batteries capacity has been
increased from just over 24 to nearly 36
kilowatt hours
the steam Ilyich mutters realizes that
the developers of electric cars face
unique challenges when it comes to the
ambient sound since the motor is so
quiet the occupants can hear every
squeak and creak in the seats the - and
the body under cover sunny about here an
eagle at the ego produces not even a
rattle rattle DS by DT just as montes
can switch between driving modes for the
GT e--'s hybrid system the ego offers a
choice of three driving modes normal eco
and eco plus the plus mode is especially
useful as the car reaches the end of its
range it shuts down all the other energy
consumers air-conditioning for instance
and might extend the range just enough
to reach your destination nice bite of
an onion the new generation lithium-ion
battery has about 50 percent more power
and the difference is noticeable the
powertrain achieves a respectable 100
kilowatts and an impressive 290 Newton
meters of torque right from the start
the electric motors thrust does not
depend on the revs pick up like that
more than makes up for the absence of a
gasoline engine
the updates for Montes concludes that
the golf GTE and ego of updates show the
move toward electric drive is making
progress ranges are growing and the cars
are fun to drive so he thinks they ought
to attract more buyers but if drivers
truly want to reduce their carbon
footprints they'll have to make sure
they recharge their electric cars from
renewable energy sources like
hydroelectric wind or solar power in
cuffed or azolla and Agee comes
Banta for ten years ago no one ever
dreamt off-road vehicles would take over
the cities but to car tester on delayed
Zimmerman it seems as if today the
entire automotive industry revolves
around them pickups are a coming thing
even Mercedes has plans to build one so
why not take a look at the market leader
the Ford Ranger Ranger pickups haven't
been great sellers in Germany up to now
but they're still one of Ford's
mainstays the larger f150 that's sold in
America is one of the three most widely
sold cars in the world in Europe you'll
have to settle for the smaller Ranger
but it's Europe's number one pick up
[Music]
as unfunctional at first Andre had his
doubts about the Ranger he couldn't
imagine being happy with it for long but
after getting acquainted with it he
realized it's a trusty companion but it
does have some drawbacks for example the
off-road tires make the Ranger a bit
loud in the interior but Andre says you
soon get used to that collective snare
outside to the big tire lugs make the
Ranger loud this Rangers 2.2 litre 118
kilowatt diesel engine is not the
quietest but Andre says it's sound only
really gets on your nerves when you
accelerate on a cold engine as I said
Andre says people like SUVs because
sitting high provides a better view of
the road but a ranger driver towers over
most SUVs and could spit on the roof of
a VW tiguan and on the highway a Ranger
driver feels closer to the truck drivers
than to car drivers that's part of the
charm of this Rough Rider I found not
some Shawn Biden is that our bosses here
for food
no wonder the Ranger is 1.85 meters high
almost twenty centimeters taller than
the current ego on the Ranger also
offers more assistance systems than you
might expect
you pry the phonetics many of the extras
don't come cheap but Andre thinks they
are worth it on offer our sink voice
control a traffic sign recognition
system and a lane departure warning
system on today's favorite is the
adaptive cruise control which maintains
a set distance from the car in front
that makes highway driving safer and
more comfortable the Ranger offers
additional technical refinements for
off-road driving a switchable all-wheel
drive with high gear reduction is
helpful in rough terrain an additional
off-road package with under ride
protection and a switchable differential
lock in the back costs about 400 extra
but if like us in our test you stick to
forest roads for example to gather
firewood
you won't need all-wheel gear reduction
or a differential lock the Ranger is
already widely used as a construction
site vehicle
[Music]
busy find fault ranges a Ford Ranger is
definitely a utility vehicle says Andre
but who is really disturbed by a hard
plastic dashboard or that down here
the craftsmanship doesn't sound tip-top
Andre would have liked softer padding on
the door but the steering wheel is
top-notch
a clever detail is the cooled
compartment in the center armrest the
Rangers robust boxy exterior puts the
vehicle's rough nature right out there
[Music]
the limited version comes with a
chrome-plated sports row bar over the
flatbed at no extra charge a useful
option is a lockable roller cover for
the bed but this variant costs almost
2,000 euros life stylistic car
manufactures toss around the word
lifestyle with every model these days as
Andre but he thinks the term is
appropriate for the Ford Ranger it is a
lifestyle truck because he could throw
his mountain bike or snowboards onto the
bed and the Ranger will pull the horse
trailer a mobile home or maybe even a
racing car with its one-time load
capacity and three and a half 10 towing
capacity the Ranger serves any hobby
well mocked arranger of Unitas hobby
myth one of the seventh generation of
BMW 5-series is the new BMW 530i
performance on the road this plug-in
hybrid can cover up to 650 kilometers 50
of them on electric drive only and the
battery takes less than five hours to
recharge completely on a household
outlet and Germany the government
ecological bonus brings the price down
to under fifty thousand euros
Lamborghini has rolled out a new model
for its hurricane series the hurricane
powerful monta a new active aerodynamic
system was developed especially for the
sports car to cut down wind resistance
the new lightweight technologies have
shaved 40 kilos off the new model the
engine too is beefed up at 470 kilowatts
it's the strongest in the lineup the
powerful Monte is set to hit German
showrooms in summer 2017 listing at 233
thousand euros
[Music]
this is it
the first seeit Ibiza it was the first
model the Spanish brand designed on its
own and the start of a great success
story Te'o Garcia was the engineer in
charge of sec he says this was his first
car he worked at C at Centro tecnico and
created it in collaboration with et al
design Giorgetto Giugiaro was the
designer both of the designer 33 years
on the fifth generation is coming onto
the market the new Ibiza is the first
car to be built on the VW group's new
MQB a zero platform the models design
has changed over the years large windows
were replaced by large C pillars to
improve safety the boxy front made way
for a more aerodynamic one in contrast
to the overall design though the SE logo
has gotten simpler over time this car
has more lines than what we used to do
normally in other designs look at for
instance at the sculpture on the on the
hood but I would say that one of the
main novelties that we have in our three
generation Ibiza is the way how we link
the lines of the hood with the lines of
the bumper it's a long road from initial
design to finish car they start with
classical drawings then move on to
computer animations that's nothing
unusual what is new is what they can do
with the finished virtual models of the
car
yes the system is the same to the to the
games but the difference is this
surfaces is the same surfaces used for
preparing models when the the CAD model
air finish the car passed to this tool
in in one hour two hours possible
prepare the car in this environment is
possible see the car in there in the
rural environments in the same form to
do you see in the in the reality it's
possible show the the same formed
exterior to the interior if the design
is approved they'll produce a large clay
model of it here traditional
craftsmanship and dexterity are still
required
you thinking that all design is for
everybody in Europe and we're thinking
that this kind of carats absolutely also
for us but also for everybody in Europe
I think all this is have the same
problems no and the same and good things
and we think this the new visa can can
be using in all the cities and all the
villages around Europe so yet also
monitors trends and fashion and
architecture to choose colors and
materials that will help the Ibiza cater
to current tastes we started this
project many years ago we started to
study the trends and
or the excellence for example with the
Carolina design this beautiful color
yeah because we saw that these kind of
colors are in increase in design of
products and materials and architecture
and it was we see this color all the
time I mean nowadays now it was a trend
that was beginning to to show in many
product designs mobile phones and so we
we thought was a could have it in the
baby self and this is what the finished
product looks like it's a typical Zia
whose appearance owes much to the 2012
say at Lyon still the II beaches look
has evolved thanks to state-of-the-art
production methods the designers can
create even more exciting edges and
creases in the body this rear lamp was
very much inspired by the rear lamp of
the first divita of 1984 but this idea
of a small lamp on the corner of the car
is something that I wanted to keep in
this field generation because it gave a
lot of personality there is no other car
with such as small restraint lamp and I
think that is probably the most
beautiful corner of the car
but 33 years is a long time in the
rapidly changing auto industry much of
what was modern in 1984 looks antiquated
today when drivers can operate powerful
onboard computers by a touchscreen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that ended annoying to go series
production hybrids have been on the
market since the late 1990s card history
Manuel Schaefer most of them have a
futuristic appearance and load rank that
goes for the Toyota Prius the granddaddy
of all hybrid vehicles and the current
hyundai ioniq
but the kia Niro which has the same
technology as the ioniq looks like a
normal crossover SUV acaba and guns
unleavened baked Ania c10 philosophy and
guns no modest crossover SUV so at first
glance you might not believe that this
Korean model has hybrid drive it has a
system capacity of 104 kilowatts and
makes do with a very modest 4.4 liters
per 100 kilometers in combined fuel
consumption we're testing the variant
with the top trim line the spirit whose
price starts in just over 30,000 euros
in Germany but the basic version Edition
7 offers enough creature comforts to
like dual zone climate control for
example
[Music]
get down here behind the air-intake the
kia Nero has adjustable slats at high
speeds they fold shut creating an air
cushion in front of them and that makes
the air outside move past the car
lowering wind resistance me - done
[ __ ] at the Nero's exterior looks
quite modern the xenon headlights only
come with a top trim level the same goes
for the front parking sensors the spirit
variant also features 18 inch alloy rims
and tinted rear windows
[Music]
the Nero is around four point four
meters long and has a wheelbase of two
point seven meters chrome trim gives the
car and air of luxury conspicuous in the
rear are the big taillights they and the
large bumper make the car seem very
broad
[Music]
you
under the hood is a 1.6 liter gasoline
engine and a 32 kilowatt electric motor
the key annuity the Kia Niro has all
kinds of technical gadgets he manual
especially likes the inductive charging
station in the center console if you
have a compatible smartphone you just
set it down here and it charges and you
don't have to fool around with cables
and sockets the trunk offers 427 liters
of storage space fold the back seat down
and you've got 1425 liters the interior
makes a good impression - and the neros
basic version 150 euros extra will get
you a leather steering wheel the JBL
sound system with 320 watts and 7
speakers delivers very good sound and is
included in the spirit line that leather
seats will set you back an additional
1,500 euros backseat passengers have
enough legroom
a hybrid engine is very useful
especially in stop-and-go traffic the
electric motor gets you started from a
stop kia says you can run solely on the
electric engine up to 120 kilometers an
hour provided you don't stomp on the go
pedal too much unlike a plug-in hybrid
the neros battery is charged by a
regenerative braking system the
six-speed dual-clutch transmission is
efficient and makes driving a pleasure
[Music]
Daqi ánewá IKEA Nero one Amanda while
over entirely he says those wanting to
check out the competition in the
crossover hybrid segment could try the
Toyota CHR but its entry level price is
over 2500 euros higher the Nero's slowed
top speed of 162 kilometers an hour
makes it a good car for Sunday drives in
the country and every day driving in the
city here the Korean hybrid really comes
into its own
[Music]
tuning world on lake constance is
europe's largest trade fair devoted to
car customization with sports
suspensions body kits and disco lights
galore it's a celebration of the
automobile and individuality that draws
some 110,000 visitors tuners amateur and
pro are here to see and be seen and
display their automotive masterpieces
among them is professional tuner Sydney
Huffman as far as he's concerned tuning
world is the most important tuning fair
people come to show off their cars and
gather new ideas they can put into
practice right off for him this is what
kicks off every new season as I said
he's angry so that begins as his own
Commission and 2016 tuning fans spent
around 1.8 billion euros on German
tuning products to enhance their cars
looks optimize its performance or add
some personality to the car
the fifteenth tuning world also
testifies to the emancipation of the
electric car which brings up the subject
of sound engineering
[Music]
juergen Erla is certain this is the
major trend for electric cars because
they don't produce their own sound but
he thinks for the sake of pedestrian
safety
they'll have to drivers will be able to
choose the exact ambient sound they
desire this sound is genuine production
of the VW Beetle started in 1938 now
it's one of the most frequently tuned
cars on the road this year's fair
includes several tributes to the bug
Philips eyebolt is sure once you've sat
in a beetle it becomes such a passion
you'll never want to get out
Sidney Hoffman stand is an object lesson
in tuning to perfection star tuner and
wide-body artist Akira Makai of Japan
works by his own rules live onstage with
a crowd looking on he cuts and fits an
aerodynamic skirt it's one-of-a-kind
acai works only with Porsches and only
if the chemistry with the owner is right
and with Sidney Hoffman and his Porsche
993 c4 the bond is instant
hey Phillip is a Curie confirms that
their connection goes way back they
worked together before and on the basis
of that friendship when Sydney asked him
to tune his Porsche in Germany he agreed
I thought I thought I did but why would
a professional get another tuner to
makeover his car yeah doesn't Sydney
admits the question is justified of
course he prefers to work on his cars
himself but Akira
nakai isn't just anyone the decisive
factor for Sydney is that he's a true
artist not just a mechanic or an average
tuner if anybody wants a Ravel's Porsche
as Akira nakai calls his creations nakai
has to build it the handcrafted add-ons
run to at least 18,000 euros and the
artist mounts them on the car himself
this will be the second Ravel Porsche in
Sydney's collection
the tuning scene adores its stars their
talents are as diverse as their
characters the more eccentric the better
there is something for everyone and no
shortage of ideas at tuning world on
lake constance that's an invitation to
get creative
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]